[Música]
eu tô aqui hoje para falar sobre
excelência que já é meio engraçado saída
mas o único jeito de comunicar é falando
eu vou pedir pra vocês
pelo tempo da minha palestra primeiro
pra se desconectarem league seus
celulares não fotografe até porque se
vocês ficarem fotografando meu medo eu
vou ficar mais confortável ainda que é
silêncio pra vocês que é silêncio pra
nós seres humanos
há quem diga que o silêncio ele é uma
porta de entrada para quem nós somos
emocionalmente e que a gente é
emocionalmente é quem a gente é de
verdade
se você não se permite olhar pra você no
silêncio da sua cabeça você nunca vai
saber disso
quatro anos atrás estava deitado em uma
mesa no centro cirúrgico e aí fazendo
oitava cirurgia consecutivas nos olhos
nas pautas já estava tudo muito
inflamado já começou
o médico aplicou outra neste dia
e aí a dor não parou e falou muito
inflamado anestesia não vai pegar
vamos seguir quase 30 anos de obra
meditava mais de 20 do alto do meu ego
tenho certeza que dá conta
começou a era paulo abre a pálpebra pelo
seu olho é segura o equipamento dispõe
os pontos de informação primeira passada
do bisturi
uau na hora a dor passou para o próximo
nível e eu tinha certeza que não ia da
conta e aí no meio desse desse caos
dessa situação
eu lembrei de uma frase de um autor
ele falava assim o silêncio é a porta de
entrada para o estado presença lembra
daquilo
depois de 20 anos eu descobri que eu
nunca tinha estado presente quando eu
botei o pé dentro dessa sensação desse
momento de presença que é o momento onde
você não é a consequência daquilo que
você já viveu e você não é a antecipação
ansiosa que você tem pela frente em raça
é um ser humano
na hora que botei o pé lá dentro gente
que encontrei foi medo muita raiva e foi
muita frustração eu encontrei várias
emoções várias emoções que eu não sabia
que moravam dentro de mim
elas eram a consequência da história de
tudo que já tinha vivido
e aí a descoberta foi tudo o que eu já
tinha vivido estava determinando o jeito
como eu pensava
o jeito como eu agia estava determinando
o jeito como eu percebi a vida estava
determinando as minhas escolhas
agora a pouco eu pedi pra vocês
desligarem o seu lado lembra a maioria
de vocês só guardou o seu
vários de vocês
pensar é preciso outros justificaram a
importância dele aí então agora eu
queria realmente desafiar cada um de
vocês a pegar o celular pega
vocês têm me ouça todos vocês têm um
celular
desliguem ele desligue vem esse passo
não atirem de perto de você desliga
desligados os celulares coloquem eles no
chão
coloque os seus celulares no chão
coloquem as suas bolsas no chão e aí
vocês aí atrás fechem o computador
vocês com os laptops ligados feche eles
e você estava anotando os cadernos
fechem os seus cadernos por um instante
com tudo fechado
vocês não estão desconectados vocês
tiraram de perto de vocês
a ferramenta externa de conexão quem se
conecta ao ser humano
agora olhem pra esse ambiente onde vocês
estão
olhem para as paredes laterais
olhem para o teto olhem para trás olhem
pra mim
olhem pro palco e aí e olhem pro outro
ser humano que você tem a direita ea
esquerda
o olhar na cara do sujeito também é e
até um beijinho
ele estava conectado gente
vejam viram onde estão viram viram viram
fecha os olhos
feche os olhos diz cruzem as pernas
coloque as mãos nos olhos coloque as
mãos nas suas coxas pernas joelhos
agora de olhos fechados
realmente fechados alguns de vocês vão
ter um instante de resistência uma
resistência que nasce do medo o medo
qualquer medo de ficar aqui na frente
até porque esse carro nesse momento com
muito mais medo de todos vocês juntos
é um medo real medo do que tem aí dentro
medo desse mapa emocional da história de
vida de olhos fechados bem espaço comigo
lembrem de onde vocês estão
lembrem das paredes
lembrem do teto lembrem dessa das
dimensões aproximadas ao lembrarem que
vocês estão no prédio dessa universidade
em porto alegre no sul do brasil na
américa latina se localizem nesse
momento a gente está ligando um sistema
natural e sub utilizado do cérebro
humano
a gente tá ligando o sistema de
localização espacial no sistema de
localização espacial mesmo que você acha
que você não tem um forte senso
não existe um saber você sabe onde você
está no saber da sua posição e no
sistema de localização espacial
a gente acorda uma nova função uma nova
área do cérebro
nesse momento um pedaço diferente da
mente de vocês está ascendendo sabendo
onde vocês estão e deixando o sistema de
localização ligado à cinta onde vocês
estão sintam a cadeira
vocês lembram quando eles eram crianças
levavam a mão para checar a quente e
logo vocês aprenderam que um pouquinho
antes da mão tocar a chica você sente
uma temperatura e levavam os dedos para
a asa da xícara nos sentir também se
saber agora com o sistema de localização
ligado e sentindo onde vocês estão
observe-se e apliquem o sistema de
localização espacial ao seu espaço
mínimo
o volume a área que vocês ocupam dentro
dessas ao percebam a área ocupada e aí
mais do que isso sintam o que preenche a
área que vocês ocupam abre os olhos
estranho não
novo é só novo não é estranho não é
difícil é novo como é novo
a igualdade é novo como é novo inclusão
tem nada de estranho aqui é você como
você é olhar pra dentro e explorar um
sim o silêncio é se dá conta de que
muito do que a gente faz é determinado
pelo que a gente já viveu olhar pra
dentro em silêncio é ter liberdade real
de escolha
o silêncio e um estado de presença que
decorre dele e que pode se tornar um
hábito na vida da gente
são tecnologias de alto conhecimento que
estão no planeta junto com nosso
processo adotivo a mais de 10 mil anos
todas elas estão disponíveis são simples
mas são tecnologias de última geração
nós já sabemos que no futuro da evolução
da raça comunicação vai ser comunicação
direta entre o que eu sinto e o que você
sente
eu vim aqui hoje só pra dizer pra vocês
que vocês não precisam ter medo de se
desconectar porque a conexão de fato
acontece quando vocês comunicam
autenticidade pra outra autenticidade
silêncio é uma fonte de liberdade
dexter
[Aplausos]